teilt und existiert aber doch seit
jahren
ein heißer juli tag während des letzten
gaza krieges
lizzie doron schreibt in ihrem buch als
die ersten raketen in tel aviv
einschlagen
die sirenen heulen wenig zeit sich in
sicherheit zu bringen
sie greift gerade noch ihr handy bevor
sie in den schutzraum gilt
ihr herz braucht mit den einschlägen der
raketen
da lange unterdrückte nummer es ist nah
die mir palästinensischer freund
er sagte dazu ich weiß sie schießen
raketen nach tel aviv ich bin sicher sie
werden keine nach jerusalem später nimmt
seine kinder und einen mann und kommt zu
uns
es war der höhepunkt einer freundschaft
die anfangs schier unmöglich schien
in ihrem roman beschreibt lizzie doron
wie sina team fünf jahre zuvor an einer
friedenskonferenz in rom trifft er
palästinenser aus ost-jerusalem
die jüdische israelin aus tel aviv
die unterschiede könnten nicht größer
sein
trotzdem es beginnt das projekt einer
freundschaft
als er das erste mal vor ihrer schicken
tel aviver wohnung stehe zweifelt er
dass er rein gelassen wird
weißt du dass dies das erste mal ist
dass sich in der wohnung von juden bin
sagte marin es verschlug es die sprache
als ich vor deiner tür stand hatte ich
angst du würdest nicht aufmachen
drinnen wird der küchentisch zum
schlachtfeld ihre vorurteile
wie kommt es dass du keine brave
sprichst sagte sie nadim antwortete weil
ich wie der terrorist noch handwerker
bin du weißt bestimmt dass unsere
gefangenen von euch hebräisch unterricht
bekommen und die handwerker eure sprache
sprechen ihren lebensunterhalt zu
verdienen
wir mussten jedes wort auf die
waagschale legen es war so aufgeladen
und belastet dass jedes wort alles in
dieser küche hätte explodieren lassen
können aber
ein stück schokolade in guter buchen
oder nur eine suppe diesen wintertagen
waren eine wunderbare therapie um das
problem zu lösen
es dauert lange bis sie sich aus dem
sicheren tel aviv ins palästinensische
ost-jerusalem wagt
er lebt mit seiner familie in zehn
wochen ausgerechnet dem stadtteil in dem
die intifada auf die radikal orthodoxen
siedler breit
ein palästinenser in begleitung einer
israelin ist stoff für beide seiten
ich glaubte nicht dass ich
war voller albträume und war sicher
erstochen zu werden
was interessant war es war ruhig
rundherum
linken sein haus und begannen zu rufen
verräterin verräterin wir werden dich
töten
es ist die angst vor radikalismus aus
den eigenen reihen der die beiden
vereint
aber es trennen sie welten wenn es um
die israelischen checkpoints geht für
sie eine notwendige sicherheit für ihn
eine lebensbedrohliche schikane
es machte ihn verrückt zu sehen dass ich
niemals verstehen würde was ein
checkpoint für ihn bedeutet
weil wenn ich an einem checkpoint war
sich der soldat immer anders behandeln
würde als ihn
ein balance-akt am ende will er nicht
dass sein richtiger name publik wird und
in ihrem buch steht aus angst ihre
freundschaft sterbe die angesagtesten
nachdem ich ihn getroffen habe weiß ich
nicht mehr was freundschaft ist nachdem
wir eine solche verbindung an ein
solches engagement und die gleichen
interessen teilten um etwas zu
produzieren
es ist der gedanke dass wir nur freunde
sind weil wir feinde und nichts anderes
uns dazu brachte hier am tisch zu sitzen
und zusammen zu frühstücken
residence geschichte erzählt von einer
unmöglichen freundschaft die trotz allem
über die jahre gewachsen ist
das muss